[Musik]
ausschreitungen in berlin in einer nacht
der krawalle werden 93 polizisten
verletzt
ein land in trauer israel gedenkt der
opfer der massenpanik und sucht die
verantwortlichen des unglücks
führungskrise beim dfb
die landesverbände fordern präsident
keller un-generalsekretär kurzes zum
rücktritt auf
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster
wir kommen bei den nachrichten am
sonntag norbert lehmann und der sport in
wenigen minuten ein schoko land oder von
mir trotz corona hatten gestern am tag
der arbeit traditionsgemäß tausende in
westdeutschen großstädten demonstriert
tagsüber meist friedlich am späten abend
dann weniger da flogen wie so oft am
ersten mai böller flaschen und steine
brannten mülltonnen und barrikaden
allein in berlin wurden 93 beamtinnen
und beamte verletzt die polizei nahm 354
randalierende fest und hatte einiges zu
tun um die lage bis mitternacht zu
beruhigen
roman les cover ein erster mai wien
berlin länger nicht erlebte knapp 100
teils schwerer verletzte polizistinnen
und polizisten so viel wie seit neun
jahren nicht ausschreitungen während der
demo der linken und linksextremen szene
schon kurz nach beginn werden verstöße
gegen die abstands auflagen bemängelt
als die einsatzkräfte eingreifen
eskaliert die situation
trotzdem im vergleich zu früheren jahren
spricht die polizei am tag danach von
einem nur kurzen gewaltausbruch es geht
um in etwa 90 minuten in denen diese
ausschreitungen stattgefunden haben das
heißt wir konnten diese lage sehr sehr
schnell wieder unter kontrolle bringen
auch in anderen städten wie hier in
frankfurt am main kam es zu gewaltsamen
auseinandersetzungen
mehrere tausend teilnehmerinnen
thema waren einem aufruf aus der
linksradikalen szene gefolgt auch hier
kam es zu festnahmen und verletzte in
hamburg gab es starke einschränkungen
für demonstrationen einzelne
versammlungen hatten die behörden im
vorfeld untersagt wie hier im
schanzenviertel wurden zusammenkünfte
auf genutzt zum teil wurde der
mindestabstand nicht eingehalten und
auch hier handelt es sich eben um eine
versammlung die nicht angemeldet war und
deswegen aufzulösen war
doch solche bilder gab es in diesem jahr
friedlicher proteste unter krone
bedingungen eine fahrrad demo gegen die
mietenentwicklung in berlin mit rund
10.000 teilnehmenden zählte sie dabei zu
den größten in deutschland
das impfen in deutschland geht voran
neben arztpraxen und impfzentren sollen
spätestens ab siebten juni auch
betriebsärzte und ärztinnen mit
einbezogen werden
laut bundesgesundheitsministerium sind
für sie zunächst mindestens 500.000
dosen pro woche vorgesehen
möglich wird das weil nach und nach
immer mehr impfstoff geliefert wird und
jetzt der tägliche blick auf die
aktuellen krone zahlen
da zeigt sich eine positive entwicklung
bei den neuinfektionen sie sind weiter
rückläufig 16290 neue fälle wurden laut
robert koch-institut binnen 24 stunden
registriert 2483 weniger als vergangenen
sonntag 110 todesfälle kamen hinzu
auch die bundesweite sieben tage
incidents sinkt leicht auf 146,5 ein
brennpunkt der epidemie ist und bleibt
brasilien
der april war der bisher tödlichste
monat
inzwischen betreut das land mehr als
400.000 coroner tote jeden tag sterben
knapp 2000 menschen die schuld sehen
viele bei präsident ball so nahrung bis
heute verharmlost er das virus stemmt
sich gegen harte maßnahmen zweifelt
öffentlich am sinn des impfens christoph
reckert
es sind tausende die zum ersten mai auf
die straße gehen für ihren präsidenten
trotz der verheerenden corona bilanz
halten sie ihm die treue ball so nahe
ist eine legende ich verteidige ihn mit
aller kraft
doch die opposition im kongress will die
bolzen a row regierung jetzt zur
rechenschaft ziehen
sie wirft ihr vor für die 400.000 toten
verantwortlich zu sein
durch unterlassen inkompetenz und lügen
wenn wir es beweisen können werden wir
sie belangen das ist unsere antwort um
mit dem rest der welt im gleichklang zu
sein verbrechen gegen die menschlichkeit
verjähren szenario hier vor wenigen
tagen bei der einweihung einer autobahn
gibt sich unbeirrt
ich habe keine angst vor dem
untersuchungsausschuss wir schulden
niemandem etwas
der untersuchungsausschuss könnte zum
problem werden für präsident portion
euro der im nächsten jahr wiedergewählt
werden will
bisher kann er seine anhänger
mobilisieren mit seinen eigenen
wahrheiten eine offizielle untersuchung
der fakten aber könnte dieses bild ins
wanken bringen und die opposition
stärken
seit anfang des jahres hat sich die zahl
der korona toten verdoppelt 400
symbolische leichensäcke haben
demonstranten am strand der copacabana
ausgelegt jeder steht für 1000 tote das
land hat dabei zugesehen die seine
menschen erstickt sind
die szene die wir hier nach stellen
steht sinnbildlich für den moment den
wir gerade erleben ein moment der auf
absehbare zeit nicht vorüber gehen
dürfte denn ein kurswechsel der ball
zennaro regierung ist nicht in sicht
staatstrauer in israel das land gedenkt
heute der menschen die vor drei tagen
opfer der massenpanik an einem
wallfahrtsort wurden die flaggen wehen
auf halbmast viele veranstaltungen sind
abgesagt während eines religiösen festes
mit etwa 100000 teilnehmern waren
menschen auf einer rampe ins rutschen
gekommen 45 gläubige starben 150 wurden
verletzt
mittlerweile laufen ermittlungen zur
unglücksursache es gibt auch
rücktrittsforderungen an einzelne
minister ja da kann uns sicher michael
bewerunge in tel aviv weiterhelfen
michael was wirft man denn
bis dann denn vor
er hat das besonders schlimme an diesem
unglück ist eben das ist ein unglück mit
ansage gewesen ist seit über einem
jahrzehnt waren regionale behörden
stellen in schriftlichen berichten genau
vor den schwachstellen die
wahrscheinlich am donnerstag den pilgern
zum verhängnis geworden sind zu wenig
notausgänge zu enge fluchtwege eine
infrastruktur die insgesamt nicht auf
solche pilgermassen ausgelegt ist aber
die ultra dort orthodoxie ist eine macht
im staat israel und nach den bisherigen
informationen berichten setzt sich ein
bild zusammen nach der so eine art
unheilvolle allianz zwischen den
religiösen führern ihren politischen
vertretern im kabinett liegt minister
bis hin zu premierminister netanjahu
gegeben hat die immer wieder eine
reduktion der teilnehmerzahl verändert
hat so auch zuletzt im kabinett wo
anscheinend konkret auch bei diesem
ereignis über eine reduktion gesprochen
worden ist nach der zeit der trauer ist
jetzt die zeit für antworten bekommen ja
hintergründe von michael b warum mir
vielen dank dafür nach tel aviv
kein ende der gewalt in myanmar
bei neuen protesten gegen die
militärmachthaber sind fünf menschen
getötet worden
tausende forderten erneut eine rückkehr
zur demokratie
das militär hatte anfang februar die
demokratisch gewählte regierung
abgesetzt
seitdem kamen mehr als 750 menschen bei
straßenprotesten ums leben
und damit sind wir schon beim sport und
beim krisen gipfel beim deutschen
fußball-bund heute in potsdam die arbeit
unter stand livni präsident fritz keller
mächtig unter druck
er hatte ja sein vize rainer koch im
streit mit einem nazi richter verglichen
jetzt fordern die landes und
regionalverbände kellers rücktritt es
sind archivbilder
nun ist das tischtuch zerschnitten
zwischen db präsident keller links und
seinem vertreter rainer koch nach
kellers verbale entgleisung mit dem
vergleich zwischen koch und im nazi
richter freisler reagieren in potsdam
die landesverbände im dauer
führungsstreit des dfb
eine derartige äußerung ist völlig
inakzeptabel und macht uns fassungslos
für die regionalverbände unvereinbar mit
werten und haltung
vor diesem hintergrund haben die
präsidenten der landes- und
regionalverbände des deutschen fußball
bundes auf der außerordentlichen
konferenz an diesem wochenende hier in
potsdam
fritz keller das vertrauen entzogen und
ihn aufgefordert von seinem amt
zurückzutreten
auch dem generalsekretär friedrich kurz
hus wird das vertrauen entzogen
was passiert in dem verband alles es
gibt laufende verfahren der
staatsanwaltschaft es gibt laufende
steuerermittlungen es gibt diese
sommermärchen affäre und immer wieder
intrigen und machtkämpfe ein
führungsstreit der auch sein ende
zusteuert keller und kurzes schweigen
noch jetzt hatte dfb-vorstand das letzte
wort die fußballerinnen von bayern
münchen sind im champions league
halbfinale gegen chelsea in london
ausgeschieden
dabei hatten die münchnerinnen durch den
1 1-ausgleichstreffer hindern 29 minute
durch zara zara ziel gute karten
das im spiel hatte münchen ja mit 2 1
gewonnen danach allerdings drei treffer
von chelsea fremdkörper traf zum 4 2
1-endstand im endspiel dagegen steht der
bvb durch das souveräne 5 10 uhr gestern
abend im dfb pokalhalbfinale gegen
zweitligist holstein kiel die dortmunder
treffen dann am 13 mai in berlin auf rb
leipzig und zur formel 1 da hat
weltmeister lewis hamilton den großen
preis von portugal gewonnen
der mercedes pilot siegte vor max
verstappen in red bull und seinem
teamkollegen valtteri bottas sebastian
vettel holte im ersten martin als
dreizehnter sein bestes resultat der
saison verpasste aber erneut die
punkteränge
das was von sport und uns bleibt noch
der blick aufs wetter morgen im
nordosten schauer die zum mittag ab
ziehen im nordwesten regnet es dann am
nachmittag wieder im süden ist es länger
sonnig 10 bis 17 grad
das war es in aller kürze schön dass sie
dabei waren
christian sievers mit dem heute-journal
zur gewohnten zeit um drei viertel 10
und morgen freut sich barbara
weg an dieser stelle hier auf sie ich
wünsche ihnen noch einen sehr schönen
sonntagabend und übergebe jetzt an
berlin direkt und theo koll